[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Jean Ross
vice president of evangelism for amazing
facts hello friends how about an amazing
fact one small step for man one giant
leap for mankind
these words are the famous words spoken
by Neil Armstrong as he made the first
human footprints on the moon 50 years
ago on July the 20th 1969 an estimated
600 million people around the world
watch live as the first human stepped
onto another astronomical body the moon
it's amazing to think that just 66 years
earlier in 1903 the Wright brothers flew
their self powered aeroplane for the
first time opening up the age of human
flight to commemorate the remarkable
achievements in flight Neil Armstrong
took with him to the moon a piece of
wood from the Wright brothers in 1903
airplanes left propeller and a piece of
fabric from the upper left wing little
could the Wright brothers have imagined
that part of their aeroplane would one
day go to the moon and back
although the Apollo 11 mission turned
out to be a tremendous success at the
time of the launch the mission was very
risky so risk in fact that President
Richard Nixon had a speech already
prepared in case of a catastrophe after
all nobody had ever landed on the moon
before and he was not quite sure if it
is even possible to take off from the
lunar surface in order to return back to
the earth but thankfully the speech was
never needed did you know friends that
the Bible predicts that in the
not-too-distant future mankind will
travel much further than the moon stay
tuned for more as amazing facts brings
you this edition of
ances life you're listening to Bible
answers live honest answers to your
Bible questions this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode to receive
any of the Bible resources mentioned in
this evening's program call 888-814-3923
source phone line and we'll be
mentioning different free offers that we
have that'll help you in your study of
God's Word I just call that number eight
hundred eighty three five six seven four
seven as for the free offer we'll be
happy to send it to anyone in North
America if you're outside of North
America just go to the amazing facts and
web site we have a free librarian you'll
be able to read the various resources
there as well
we'd like to greet our friends or
joining us on Facebook this evening hi
know that we have viewers across North
America even some in other countries
that tune in week after week to
participate in Bible answers live well
before we get to our calls and the Bible
let's begin with the word of Prayer dear
father we thank you that we have this
opportunity once again to open up your
word and study the most important book
and that is the Bible reveals to us a
savior reveals to us a way to have
everlasting life and so we ask your
blessing upon our time be with those who
are listening wherever they might be
and thank you Father for your promise to
be with us in Jesus name Amen
I open the program this evening by
talking a little bit about that
remarkable event that occurred 50 years
ago back in 1969 July the 20th and when
you think about the incredible
achievement I've been able to go to the
moon and everything that was involved
especially back in 1969
or all of the digital abilities that we
have today it was remarkable but you
know the Bible talks about a traveling
in space not to the moon and not even to
Mars but it really talks about a journey
to a heavenly City in John chapter 14
verse 1 we read the words of Jesus he
said let not your hearts be troubled you
believe in God believe also in me in my
father's house there are many mansions
if it were not so I would have told you
I go to prepare a place for you and if I
go and prepare a place for you I will
come again and receive you unto myself
that where I am there you may be also
so here we find Jesus telling his
disciples and also telling us that he is
preparing a place for those that love
him and he promised that he would come
back again and take us to that heavenly
home to that city made of gold that we
read about in the Bible and of course
that is the goal of every Christian to
be faithful to have Jesus comes
sometimes referred to as the great hope
of the Christian the great Evon hope the
second coming of Jesus if you'd like to
learn more about what the Bible has to
say about the second coming we have a
free offer we'd like to send you it is
one of our amazing facts study guides
and it's entitled the ultimate
deliverance the ultimate deliverance
it's all about the second coming gives
you a number of Bible verses important
information just call we'll send it to
you for free the number is 883 five six
seven four seven and you can ask for the
study guide called the ultimate
deliverance again that number is 885 six
seven four seven and our phone line here
to the studios evening is eight hundred
four six three seven two nine seven
we're gonna go to our first caller
tonight we have William listening in
Davis California William welcome to the
program oh hi are you on the air awesome
and you're Christian this evening
my question is what are the test of a
true prophet okay good question well the
bible does speak about prophecy as being
one of the gifts that god has given his
church and we see throughout scripture
many instances where god spoke to people
through
a prophet and the Bible also warns us
though Christ Himself warned us that in
the last days there would be false
prophets and so we need to know is this
a genuine manifestation of the gift of
prophecy or is this a counterfeit
manifestation is this the devil trying
to deceive well the bible does give us
certain identifying marks to determine
whether somebody who says they have the
gift of prophecy is indeed a prophet
number one what they say must be in
harmony with the Word of God
to the law and to the testimony if they
speak not according to this the Bible
says there is no light in them so that's
probably the most important test right
away is do they speak in harmony with
the Scriptures the second test that
needs to be applied is what about their
life jesus said by their fruits you
shall know them
what kind of a life does this person
live what do others say about the person
are they genuinely committed to Christ
are they genuine Christian one of the
things that I think you'll be able to
distinguish right away is if somebody is
asking for money in order for them to
prophesy if you've got a question that
immediately because your is in the Old
Testament and even in the new people
didn't get paid to give a message from
God so that's another test also you need
to ask does their predictions come true
somebody predicts something to happen
and it doesn't happen well then that's
not a true prophet of God so those are
three of the tests that we have and
there are more and we actually have a
study guide William you might have seen
it I'm not sure if you haven't we'd like
to encourage you to take a look at it
it's called does God inspire
astrologists and psychics it's a long
title but basically it's talking about
the gift of prophecy how do we know a
genuine prophet from a counterfeit
prophet and we'll be happy to send this
to anyone who calls an ass the number is
883 five six seven four seven and again
just as for that study guide talking
about distinguishing true and false
prophets well um did that help yes thank
you
all right thanks your call our next
caller that we have is Leah listening in
Ontario Canada Leah welcome to the
program hi pastor thank you so much I
have a question about a tea
the Fab Four especially for children at
this time our chill-out our church is
planning to build a playground for our
children because hobbit is a delightful
day you know but so do we want picture
to enjoy good by painting a grand tube
but some of the member things this is a
Sabbath day we're supposed to keep the
Sabbath holy why we why we allow our
children to play in the playground so
basically my question is what is your
feel about this thing okay so the
question is what about kids playing in a
playground on the Sabbath I think if you
look at the biblical principles that we
find in the Bible referring to the
Sabbath the Sabbath needs to be a day
that is set aside from typical normal
weekly activity now the Sabbath is not
to be a day of gloom and sadness and for
the children it's probably important to
make it special for them but in keeping
with the spirit of the Sabbath
if their regular routine is playing on
the playground all through the week and
that's they main focus it would probably
be better to plan something a little
different something special the Sabbath
is a great opportunity to go out into
nature to see God's work to spend time
talking about our Creator you know again
I wouldn't condemn someone or a kid
that's sitting on a swing on the Sabbath
don't don't misunderstand me but if the
focus of the children are just running
around climbing and jumping and typical
kids activities on the Sabbath maybe we
could find something a little better for
them to do on the Sabbath so I guess
that would be my guidance there I know
growing up I grew up in a Christian home
where we kept the Sabbath and there was
always something special planned on a
Sabbath afternoon
something that we look forward to as
children typically it would be out in
nature doing involve hiking it would be
exploring new places that we haven't
seen so that's kind of the thing that we
want to plan for we need to think about
what can we do to make the Sabbath
special for our children thank you so
much pastor all right thank you for your
kolya appreciate it
you're listening to Bible answers live
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific time call us at
one eight hundred seven floors
hi Charles welcome to the program hey
Pastor Ross how are you doing well my
Bible question is this about the seven
last plagues that the Bible mentions are
there signs that I should look forward
to know when that there's that they're
starting to take place I mean what would
I what would I need to look for okay
the seven last plagues we read about in
the book of Revelation and they take
place just prior to the coming of Christ
the civilized place don't begin to fall
until everybody has had an opportunity
to make a decision for Christ or against
him in Revelation chapter 7 you start
there in verse 1 it talks about an angel
coming from heaven with a seal in his
hand and he says to the four angels to
whom it was given to release the winds
of strife do not let go until we have
sealed the servants of God in their
foreheads
so there is a work of sealing a settling
into the truth into commitment to Christ
probation lien closes just as the door
closed and Noah's Ark and then you have
the seven last plates that fall the
purpose of the civilized plagues is to
hard
ripen the harvest the second coming of
Jesus is often described as a harvest of
the earth and it reveals the true nature
of the wicked it also reveals the true
nature of the righteous and their full
dependence upon God
so the plagues as described in the book
of Revelation they don't take place
until after probation closes as you read
in Revelation chapter 7 okay that makes
a lot of sense thank you very much
all right thanks your call good question
next caller that we have is Charles and
actually Chris Chris is listening in
Florida as well hi Chris welcome to the
program thank you Pastor good evening hi
and your question this evening
yes my question is about rewards in
heaven yes it's about I believe it's
about those that are saved and I have
two scriptures here Matthew 16:27 and
second Corinthians sighs Karen all right
well let me read Matthew 16:27 for those
who are listening they might be driving
these are the words of Jesus he said for
the Son of Man will come in the glory of
his father with his angels and then he
will reward each according to his works
and then the other verse that I think
you're referring to there you said he's
2nd Corinthians 5:10 oh yes it says for
we must all appear before the judgment
seat of Christ that each one may receive
the things done in this body according
to that which he has done whether it be
good or whether it be bad and I can
actually add in there one more verse
there revelation 22 it speaks of Jesus
coming he says behold I come quickly and
my reward is with me to give every man
according to his works so yes there are
rewards that are given when Jesus comes
then not only do you have the saved and
the lost but you also have those who
have lived a life of devotion to Christ
who maybe have gone through great
hardship for their faith maybe they have
even given their life for Christ as a
testimony of their faith and each is
rewarded according to his works what he
has done and so yes there are rewards
given in heaven let me ask this so we
all will experience that presence of God
in different way a while in heaven well
you know I think with me according to
our deed well when we get to first of
all to you know as far as I'm concerned
to get to heaven he's probably the
greatest reward then anyone can have
just to be there to be with God I mean
what more could anyone want but God also
recognizes the sacrifice that some of
his faithful followers have have done
for his name for the cause for the
preaching of the gospel you know you
have missionaries that have traveled
left home
left family gone to some distant land to
share the gospel with others and nobody
here might take note of that or nobody
might recognize this service but it is
noted in heaven and when Jesus comes he
rewards each according to his works now
having said that I don't think anyone's
gonna be in heaven and feel as though
they've been shortchanged
I think anyone everyone that gets to
heaven he's gonna just be delighted to
be there no one's gonna feel as though
oh man
you gave him that and you didn't give
that to me no that's not the case
I think the Bible describes that when we
get to heaven we will feel our total
dependence upon Christ and we all lay
our crowns at his feet and worship Him
and worship God but God is a God of love
he's a God of fairness and yes he does
reward not only other righteous rewarded
according to their works
but the wicked are also judged and they
receive their punishment also according
to their works
thank you very much thank you all right
thanks for your call Chris appreciate it
our next caller that we have I think
we've got Raymond listing in Bakersfield
Raymond welcome to the program hello
thank you thank you thanks for your call
and your question this evening it's
about forgiveness and and how we can
quench the Holy Spirit okay so a person
is a asking for help from Christ to get
out of a trouble and it appears that
it's not happening and then and then the
thought comes across well well maybe
maybe Satan would help what a dumb
thought but but some of the person has
this thought and then and then now even
though is willing to accept the help of
Satan would help but
but Satan doesn't help either now now is
that something you know that a person
would consider and in his mind and in
his heart I reckon is that something
that would would place the Holy Spirit
is that something that would not be
forgiven you know we always hear about
you know the unpardonable son yes yeah
the verse that I think you're referring
to is where Jesus said every son shall
be forgiven man except blasphemy against
the Holy Spirit
so people wonder what is that does that
involve some type of statement a person
make or sort of the scenario that you
painted that would would that be blessed
I'm against the Holy Spirit
choosing the devil to understand what
Blaster against the Holy Spirit is we
need to understand what the word
blasphemy means if you look in the Bible
what blasphemy means it's defined two
ways number one claiming to be able to
forgive sins and number two putting
yourself in the place of God the
religious leaders wanted to stone Jesus
they accused him of blasphemy because
Jesus forgave people of their sons
of course he could he was God and Jesus
said he was the son of God and they said
nope that's blasphemy
when we blaspheme against the Holy
Spirit in essence what that means is we
put ourselves in the place of the Holy
Spirit meaning that we get to decide
what is sin and what's not sin or what
is acceptable or what's not acceptable
instead of allowing the Holy Spirit
through the Word of God to guide us we
begin to make excuses for sin and
eventually as we harden our hearts
against the the Holy Spirit they reaches
a point where we don't hear the Holy
Spirit anymore
that's the unpardonable son or that is
blasphemy against the Holy Spirit it's
not one particular sin that a person
does it's something that takes time
it's the hardening of the heart against
the Holy Spirit the very fact that
somebody is wondering whether or not
they committed the unpardonable sin is
evidence in itself that the Holy Spirit
is still speaking to them people who
have committed the unpardonable sin
typically they don't care they have no
interest in spiritual things they don't
care whether or not they committed the
unpardonable sin so the fact that one is
wondering that's probably evidence that
the Holy Spirit is still working I
appreciate that thank you very much all
right and you know Raymond don't get
discouraged we we all struggle and the
Bible says a righteous man falls seven
times and yet he gets up so as long as
you keep trusting in Jesus he's able to
help us through every need and just
claim him as your Savior all right god
bless you Raymond we do have a book by
the way that you might find interesting
it says what is it's called what is the
unpardonable sin and we'll be happy to
send that to anyone who calls and asks
the number to call is eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
that is the
phone line and again pass for the book
on the unpardonable sin you're listening
to Bible answers live this broadcast is
a previously recorded episode to receive
any of the Bible resources mentioned in
this broadcast call 885 six seven four
seven once again
that's eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven next we have his
Ralph and he's listening in Atlanta
Ralph welcome to the program billion
pastor Ralph
yes hi my question to you is Joseph when
Joseph passed away in his descendants
passed away at the time and they were
taken into slavery they do anything to
anger God to allow them to go into
slavery well initially when they went
down into Egypt it was to preserve their
life because there's terrible famine
that was taking place in the land but
there was a second reason why God
allowed Joseph to go down into Egypt you
read a little earlier in the story of
Jacob sons
we're actually doing this you know
Tuesday Bible study that we have with
the church we were studying through the
book of Genesis and it's interesting to
note that a number of the sons of Jacob
were beginning to adopt some of the
practices of the pagan nations that
surrounded them the way that the pagans
would consider what marriage is and some
of their customs and in order for God to
preserve the descendants of Jacob in
order for him to work through them
it was probably necessary for them to be
separated from those nations that
surrounded them in Canaan when they went
down to Egypt you remember the story
they were somewhat isolated because the
Egyptians didn't really like the Hebrews
they they didn't like shepherds and the
Hebrews were shepherds they they had
cattle and sheep and and so they was set
off by themselves somewhat isolated from
the rest of the Egyptians and and that
continued for a while during Joseph and
his sons but as time went on they began
to adopt once again and began to
identify more and more with the
Egyptians some
the customs the practices and they
eventually began setting aside the
principles of what they need to be right
and that kind of opened up the way into
slavery for them and that's why we Moses
came to deliver them he had to remind
them of the things that God had
commanded them through their ancestors
and of course God brought them up to
Mount Sinai and here to give his law
because they to a large degree had set
it aside
that God punched him for for those
transgressions well I think slavery
would be a terrible punishment that they
would have it's sort of twofold
God allowed slavery for for the
descendants of Jacob in one way to
preserve them as much as possible from
the evil influences and it was also for
them to realize they need of God and
their dependence upon God so it was a
learning experience that God was
bringing the Israelites through in order
to prepare them for their re-entry into
Canaan and doing the work that God
wanted them to do alright thanks for
your call Ralph and if you have a Bible
question our phone line here friends if
you're listening is eight hundred four
six three seven two nine seven we have a
couple of lines open good time to pick
up your phone and give us a call 800
four six three seven two nine seven we
have jam that is listening from Kent
wood Michigan gen welcome to the program
hi how are you doing pastor doing well
thank you
I have a question um I have people that
sometimes they ask me about the well the
foods that we eat about clean and
unclean okay and I quote them from the
Book of Leviticus yes but then they come
and they come back and throw at me the
first book of Timothy in chapter four
verses four and five mm-hm so what do
you what do you got to say about that
all right let me read it that's right
here we find it in first Timothy chapter
four verse four talking about food it
says for every creature of God is good
and nothing to be refused if it is
saved with Thanksgiving so some people
think well it doesn't matter what you
eat as long as you pray over it somehow
whatever you eat is not gonna harm you
well the Bible also tells us that our
bodies are the temple of the holy spirit
so we want to take care of our bodies we
also know that certain things are
harmful we don't want to eat it but I
think what a lot of people leave out is
verse five verse five is the key it says
for it is sanctified by the Word of God
and prayer so are there certain foods
that are sanctified by the Word of God
that we read about in the Bible yes
are there certain foods that are not
sanctified to eat or certain things
they're not even foods certain things
that God does not want us to eat yes so
the key to understanding verse four what
what is it that needs to be received
with thanks thankfulness it's those
things that have been sanctified by the
Word of God the word sanctify means to
have set apart or set aside and then you
go back in the Old Testament and right
at the time of the sacrificial when the
sacrificial service was implemented you
had clean and unclean animals and then
after the flood God allowed the eating
of the clean animals but not the unclean
animals so verse five I think is the
answer so bring that bring Burt verse
five back to Leviticus right well it's a
simple question what what foods were
sanctified by the word we're sanctified
yes okay word sanctified means set apart
set apart set apart see you cleared
things up for me you're welcome thank
you
that's a good question that you have you
know we do have a study guide friends if
you're wondering about what the Bible
has to say about food and what's good to
eat and what's not good to eat our study
guide goes into this in a lot more
detail it's called God's free health
plan or what are the secrets for living
a healthy stronger longer life
well the Bible has something to say
about that it's called God's free health
plan it's one of our amazing facts study
guides and it's for free all you have to
do is call our resource phone line that
number is 885 six seven four seven and
again just ask for the study guide
called God
free health plan and why are you on the
phone asking for this free offer you
might also want to ask the person about
the amazing facts correspondence Bible
School it's free and what it is it's
actually goes through our famous amazing
facts study guide lessons it really
deals with a lot of important Bible
truths including a lot of prophetic
truths and it's free
all you need to say is I'm interested in
learning more about the study guide
cause I and will sign you up for free
we'll send you the lesson in the mail
take a look at it fill in the answer
sheets send it back to us and we will
send you out the next lesson well
friends is not the end of the program
we're just taking a short break and in a
few moments we'll be back with more
Bible questions so stay wrong we'll be
right back stay tuned Bible answers live
will return in a moment
DT no amazing fax has a free Bible
school that you can do from the comfort
of your own home it includes 27
beautifully illustrated study lessons to
aid in your study of God's Word
sign up today for this free Bible study
course by calling 184 257,000 that's one
eight four four two one five 7,000 we
know we're here but we're not here for
very long so the most important thing
would be if we could learn during this
life how to live forever this is the
central focus of amazing facts I think
it's very important for us to build
churches but if the churches lose the
message of salvation they just become
buildings and shells I think it's
important to have a medical ministry and
build hospitals but if they separate
that from the message of salvation you
just prolong a sinners life for a little
while that's why for years amazing facts
has made it our focus to present the
saving truth that sets people free and
friends we want to thank you for your
support in your gifts we'll do our very
best to convert those resources into the
currency of heaven and god bless you and
keep amazing facts in your prayers
deep within the pages of the Bible
stories of great heroes heroes of great
deeds great love
and great sacrifice but behind them is
another hero hidden in plain sight amid
the shadows he was there from the
beginning
and he'll be there until the end
discover the golden thread of a savior
woven throughout the entire bible
tapestry shadows of light seeing Jesus
in all the Bible get your copy today by
calling 855-578-6767 for 7 now let's
join Pastor Jean Ross for more Bible
answers live hello friends welcome back
this is Bible lands is live and if you
have a Bible related question now's the
opportunity to give us a call and we'll
do our best to answer the question we
have the Word of God in front of me
right here and we'll look up different
verses and we have a great number of
resources that we'll be talking about
throughout the program that will help
you in your study of the word if you
have a Bible question the phone line
again is eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven that's 800 god says
four six three seven two nine seven the
resource phone line is eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
we're gonna go to our first caller in
the second half of a program now we have
Alfredo listening from Canada Alfredo
welcome to the program hello well Fred
are you there Alfredo in Canada all
right we're gonna have to come back to
him we've got somebody listening in
Sacramento California Sacramento
California you there alley I guess it's
alley are you there yeah hi Allie you're
on the program from Macon Georgia Oh
from Georgia okay we've got the wrong
we've got the wrong number typed in year
yeah well hello I am glad I just make
one quick comment before I get to my
question yeah okay that is about the
blasphemy of the Holy Spirit right
before Jesus said that he was attuned to
testing out Devils by Beelzebub and the
Greek word in the Strong's for blasting
is word 988 and it means water so to
when he's doing something by the power
and the good works of the Holy Spirit
and they said they possibly Tunes it as
something that is done by Beelzebub
that's why he said that that's what they
were doing bless when the Holy Spirit by
calling the good work for the Holy
Spirit the works of the devil yeah and
that would be that whatever would be a
serious thing to do that now the
question you had early yes sir my
question I'm sorry my question is um
Jesus I know it was written that all of
the works that Jesus did in the Bible if
it was written it couldn't be contained
in the book but I was thinking it would
have been quite a significant sanctions
have been recorded once if he had ever
baptized any ones himself and it's not
in there and I was wondering why that
might be
okay so Jesus as far as we know did not
baptize of course John the Baptist he
did baptisms and Christ's disciples
baptized people and then in the New
Testament in the book of Acts you hear a
lot about going forth preaching the
gospel and baptizing people probably a
practical reason why Jesus did not
baptize people is there would have been
such a group of people that would have
wanted to be baptized by Jesus many of
them might not have made that decision
out of genuine conversion rather it was
to somehow say well Jesus baptized me
maybe that gave people or would give
people the impression that they better
than somebody else it might be more
bragging rights than genuine conversion
and Jesus knowing the Bible says he knew
what was in man Jesus knowing that we
have no record of him baptizing that
makes so much thing that makes so much
sense thank you so much god bless you
all right good question thanks for
calling Ellie our next caller that we
have we're gonna try Canada one more
time we have Alfredo listening Canada
how afraid are you they're going once
going twice okay we gonna go to let's
see we have Ashlee in Chattanooga
Tennessee hi Ashlee welcome to the
program hi thank you my question is kind
of a follow-up it's in first Timothy for
one through five but it's not so much
specifically about the food my question
is more related to is this a specific
circumstance you know that that's talked
about or is it more like for the Latter
day church or you know what what are
they referring to yes good good good
question if you look at the first few
verses of first Timothy chapter 4 I'm
just gonna read that so that those who
are listening that don't of a Bible
could follow along with us first Timothy
chapter 4 verse 1 says now the spirit
expressly says that in the latter times
some will depart from the faith giving
heed to deceiving spirits and the
doctrines of demons speaking lies in
hypocrisy having their own conscience
seared with a hot iron
and it says forbidding to marry and
commanding to abstain from foods which
God has created to be received with
Thanksgiving this by those who believe
and know the truth then it goes on in
verse 4 that we spoke about every
creature of God is good so some of the
things that's highlighted it says in the
last days or in the latter times people
depart from the truth so there is a
falling away that Paul is talking about
when he's writing to Timothy that would
occur in the church they would be
believers that would fall away from the
truth they would give heed to deceiving
spirits or the doctrines of demons they
they not biblical truths they're not
biblical doctrines and then it talks
about forbidding to marry and commanding
to abstain from certain foods it's
referring to a time in the Christian
church and particularly during the
Middle Ages or the Dark Ages where the
belief arose
that if you want to be holy or if you
want to work for God full-time in a
capacity as a preacher or or in the
church you needed to refrain from
marrying you you couldn't marry and of
course you have the priesthood that
developed during the dark ages in the
medieval church in the Catholic Church
which still carries over even today and
that's not in the Bible you don't find
that command anyway in Scripture where
if you want to serve God or if you want
to be more devout you don't marry so
those are some of the things that God
was revealing to Paul that he was
speaking about even before they occurred
that's also talking about abstaining
from certain foods there were a number
of traditions that came in the Christian
Church that on certain days you were not
allowed to eat certain types of food and
you were to eat other foods on different
days and these are some of the things
that we saw that happened during the
dark ages and even we still have some of
that even today in Christianity okay
well thank you so much thank you for
your ministry all right thanks for
calling
next caller that we have is David and
he's listening in Chicago Illinois
hi David welcome to the program hi how
are you doing well yeah my question is
as a Christian I'm - I'm involved both
in the church and in the world so what
kind of spirit is driving me to do this
because I love doing the work of God and
the same time I don't give up sinful
nature mm-hmm well I think what you're
experiencing is something that every
Christian if it needs to be honest or
she needs to be honest we recognize that
there is a battle raging in the heart or
in the mind on the one hand the devil is
constantly pulling at us tempting us we
have the Connell nature but on the other
hand we have the Holy Spirit that is
convicting us and we have a conscience
that we know what needs to be done on
what's right and you know every day
there's that that tug of war who we
gonna serve who we gonna choose
and I think that's why it's so important
and Jesus says this he said unless you
abide in me and I in you the branch
cannot be
fruit or another way jesus said without
me you can do nothing so maintaining a
living connection with Christ through
prayer through the study of his word
through turning our thoughts towards him
throughout the day engaging with Jesus
talking team as we even would to a
friend asking him for strength and help
making that a priority that's the only
way that we're gonna be able to overcome
the devil and and be victorious when
tempted so it's an ongoing experience
it's something we want to do every day
and that's growing and living the
Christian life no thank you all right
well thanks for calling David very
important question how do we live
practically the Christian life you know
we do have a study guide actually it's a
book that will be happy to sing to
anyone wanting to learn more about this
it's called a life in the spirit talks
about living that day-by-day life and
we'll be happy to send it to you if you
call and ask the number is 883 five six
seven four seven one to know God's plan
for our world and solutions for your
life's challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts 27
Bible study guides provide encouraging
Bible based answers to questions on
healthier relationships when Jesus will
return and much more refer to watch
while you read our brand new prophecy
encounters DVD series makes the perfect
companion set order your study guides
and DVDs today by visiting AAF bookstore
com or by calling 858 seven two seven
five we have Linda listening in Georgia
Linda welcome to the program doing well
and your question this evening my
question this evening is how do you know
if you have read the holy spirit away
alright well I think one of the reasons
that you know a person has not grieve
the Holy Spirit away is the fact that
they wandering typically somebody that
has grieved away the Holy Spirit they've
gotten to the point where they don't
care anymore
they're not interested in spiritual
things they're not interested in God
they in essence their conscience as Paul
mentioned in the verse would be really
first Timothy it says their conscience
is severed or put out so to speak they
don't listen they're not interested in
religious things if a person has the
Ziya and he's wondering that means the
Holy Spirit is still speaking to them
now having said that there might be
people that you look at and say oh man
their life is so far away from what God
would have it to be and surely they've
committed the unpardonable sin and yet
we know of many experiences where people
are converted and their lives are
completely changed so it is not for us
to know or at least to try and choose
who might have them who might not have
committed the unpardonable sin the Bible
says man looks on the output but God
looks at the heart only God knows okay
all right
well thanks for calling Linda we do at
that book that I think you'll find
interesting it's called understanding
the unpardonable sin and we'll be
sending that to anyone who calls an ass
just ask to the book on the unpardonable
son the number is 883 five six seven
four seven that is the resource phone
line
ask for the book on the unpardonable sin
next one of their behave is Lou driving
through Virginia Lee welcome to the
program
thank you so much for taking my call
please let that person know that we miss
him tonight yes he'll probably be back
next week but you're doing a great job
my question is well let me go statement
first my wife and I we have been married
this coming December 39 years and I
believe I heard that the Bible teaches
that once we get to heaven our marriage
is going to be dissolved abolished is
that true well the Bible doesn't say
that marriage will be abolished but what
the Bible does say Jesus actually says
that that we shall be as the angels we
won't be marrying and giving in marriage
so they won't be wedding ceremonies
taking place in heaven we won't be
procreating in heaven you know the
relationships that we have formed here
on this earth whether it is a a husband
wife if it is a parent and a child
if it is a best friend those
relationships don't come to an end when
you go to heaven especially you know
obviously if they in heaven as well I
think those relationships will continue
to grow
the greatest relationship of all will be
our relationship with Christ and God you
know I think the relationships will be
even be enhanced because they won't be
sent to kind of get in the way matter of
fact that's the hope of the Christian
and you lay a loved one in the grave
someone you love spouse family member
they die the great hope for the
Christian is that we get to see them
again we get to fellowship with them we
get to share eternity with them you know
we only give people the idea that
suddenly when you get to heaven you get
given divorce papers when you walk
through the gate no I think the
relationships we bond or form here on
earth are gonna continue in heaven but
there won't be marriage they won't be
procreation in heaven now the Bible says
that I have not seen nor ear heard nor
have entered into the hearts of men and
things that God has prepared but in that
love yeah absolutely
maybe that tells us that the
relationship will be even better than
what we can imagine right we can't even
imagine God's God's got something
special for everyone okay well thanks
you'll call new hopefully that helps a
little bit we've got James listening in
New York James welcome to the program
you're welcome James I think you got
your radio on in the background I hear
an echo okay radio okay can you hear me
okay
yes that's better hope I stole you a
little bit of an echo but what's your
question
nominations claim that they're their
personnel such as bishops have apostolic
succession with the powers that Christ's
original apostles had to perform
miracles etc is that a valid assumption
James I'm gonna just put you on mute
you'll be able to hear me but that way
we don't get the the echo so the
question is do the Apostles or is there
a modern counterfeit or not counterfeit
but a modern example I might say of
people that are apostles that are able
to do miracles well there are certain
individuals that God has given gifts to
one of the gifts spiritual gifts is that
of performing miracles or healing
often God will work through modern
medicine to bring healing he does
sometimes perform miraculous miracles I
don't think I get a little nervous if
somebody walks up and refers to himself
as an apostle the title apostle really
applies to those who were the
eyewitnesses of Christ those who spent
three-and-a-half years with Jesus Paul
was converted on the road to Damascus
and Jesus made him and he had the gift
of prophecy but typically the Apostles
came to an end at the time of John and
there are still in the church gifts that
God gives to different church members
but in particular the role of an apostle
we don't see a lot of that or we don't
see that today that really had to do
with the disciples those first followers
of Christ presuming the title of Bishop
doesn't automatically give them miracle
powers that there may be some that are
overly blessed by God but just being a
bishop doesn't automatically throw that
on you is that correct correct yes the
the term bishop is just simply otherwise
translated as an elder or an overseer so
there would be a pastor or someone
that's leading out in the church there
are regular church members that might
not be in a leadership position that
might have one of the gifts of the
Spirit that God has given them one of
which might be the gift of healing
so just to bear a title doesn't
necessarily mean that you have certain
gifts of healing hope that helps James
next call of it we have is Rhonda
listening in California Rhonda welcome
to the program hi thank you Pastor oz
thank you for taking my call yes
the Bible says in the beginning God
created the heavens and the earth and
this happened in six days in six days
God created the heavens and the earth
and all that's in them the definition of
heaven is there do you understand that
to mean these heavens that are in our
Milky Way galaxy or all the other
everything else they'll receive the the
word heaven in the Bible can be
understood three ways the one is the
atmosphere we talk about where the bird
to fly they fly in the heaven that means
the atmosphere the other heaven would be
where the stars are the universe you
might say and then the third heaven
would be the dwelling place of God and
when the Bible speaks of heaven for
example in Revelation 21 John says and I
saw there was a new heaven and a new
earth while he's referring there to the
atmosphere not necessarily to the
universe as a whole or to the dwelling
place of God but were there other
planets before our world was in
existence yes I believe so there were
other angels the rebellion that took
place in heaven occurred before our
earth was created you have a story in
job about the sons of God appearing
before God in heaven and Satan was there
as the representative of Earth Hebrews
chapter 1 speaks about how Jesus made
the worlds this is Hebrews 1 verse 2 and
it's the plural word for world so are
they other worlds out there yes we
believe so from the Bible
thank you that's that's very gratifying
to hear thank you and so is it also your
understanding that those worlds were
created before the six-day creation that
included the earth
you know what appears and I don't have a
Bible verse to back this up but it seems
to me that when our world was created
Adam and Eve were made and then of
course Satan deceived them and sin came
to this earth it appears that the
creation God creating are the worlds
kind of put on pause to deal with this
emergency the fall of mankind
the whole plan of redemption and how
that's playing out on this earth it
seems as though not only the angels but
even the other worlds might be watching
or seeing how God deals with this
emergency so I I don't they were created
before our world I don't think there has
been a creation since our world but that
doesn't mean that God's not going to
create again in the future
it just means right now the focus of
heaven is what's happening here on this
earth in the plan of redemption mm-hmm
thanks so much appreciate your input
okay thanks to : des
you're listening to Bible answers live
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 885 six seven four seven once again
that's 800 eight three five six seven
four seven four life-changing Christian
resources visit AF bookstore com
our next caller that we have is
listening in Albuquerque New Mexico
Charlene welcome to the program hello hi
you're on the air my question is I'm
wondering where the Book of Enoch comes
from okay you have a mention of at least
Enoch in the book of Jude Jude is the
book just before revelation and it says
at least the phrase they're talking
about Enoch it's believed to be a quote
from a manuscript or at least a letter
that apparently was around during the
time of the New Testament the reason we
don't have a book in the Bible called
Enoch is because some of the things that
were written and there were a number of
forgeries that occurred sometimes
somebody would rattle a tin and assign a
name of someone famous there was quite a
bit of that in New Testament times but
if a letter could be proven that it was
indeed written by one of the Apostles or
by Paul it was included in the New
Testament if the authorship of a letter
was somewhat questionable if any of the
teachings of the doctrine that was
written in that letter was out of
harmony with the teachings of Jesus it
was not included in the New Testament it
kind of happened over a period of time
yeah the letter would be written the way
it worked in New Testament times for
example Paul would write a letter to a
church the church would read the letter
they would be ascribing the church that
would carefully copy the letter then
often that letter was sent to another
Christian Church and the same thing
happened there so I'm going to read the
letter and it would be copied and then
sent to somebody else so of course all
of the original letters a long time gone
but we have lots of copies and then
around the end of the first century John
was the last of the Apostles all the way
up to around
ta D that's when these letters began to
be gathered and collected and organized
and eventually it became what we know
today is the New Testament so it took a
number of years it didn't just happen
immediately was during the first 100
years after Christ what about the
Kabbalah well there were other books as
well that in addition Kabbalah was one
and then you also have the apocryphal
that were written some Bibles even
include the apocryphal books they were
Jewish writings but again if if it was
not if they didn't know for sure who the
author was and if it was not recognized
as one of the Apostles or one of the
recognized leaders of the church or if
there was theological differences it was
not included in what they call the Canon
or the New Testament mm-hmm you know we
do have a book that you might find
interesting it's called the ultimate
resource and it's about the Bible tells
you of how the Bible came about and it
gives a lot more details in that and I
think you'll find an interesting
Charlene if you just call or anyone if
you just call our resource line that's
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven asks for the book called the
ultimate resource and we'll be happy to
send it out to anyone who calls and asks
next call of the behalf we have Glen
listening in Washington Glen welcome to
the program well thank you I have a
question regarding the book of
Revelation in chapter 19 verses 17
through 21 yes
referring to the Beast and his armies
defeated and I'm just curious as to the
timing of all of this it sounds like
perhaps this is when referring to the
second coming of Christ yes and I'm kind
of a little bit confused about the the
birds were filled with their flesh okay
verse 17 in verse 21 they start out it
starts out by saying that I saw an angel
standing in the Sun and he cried with a
loud voice saying to all the birds that
find the Missal heaven come and gather
together for the supper of the Great God
and then it's and then it culminates in
verse 21 and the rest were killed with
the sword which proceeded from the mouth
of him said on the horse and all the
birds were filled
with their flesh so wondering how the
birds were able to still be alive during
Christ's Second Coming okay a good
question let me let me just give her a
16 on the same chapter just so we know
that we're talking about the second
coming it's talking about Christ he's
described as coming in a white horse and
verse 16 says on his robe and on his
thigh a name is written king of kings
and Lord of lords so we know we're
talking about the second coming of
Christ remember revelation is a symbolic
book now back in Old Testament times or
in Bible times when armies would go to
battle and it was a great battle or a
great war the defeated army typically
they wouldn't be buried unless it was in
a city or a place where people were
living often these battles would take
place in a valley outside of the city or
you know in the woods or something like
that
and quite often the bodies of the
defeated army would lie on the ground
and the birds would be filled and the
wild animals so it's using a an imagery
or a description here in Revelation
chapter 19 it's talking about the great
day of the Battle of Armageddon where
the armies of God are coming to destroy
God's people and Jesus comes and the
wicked are destroyed so it's a symbolic
reference there to complete and how to
defeat of the enemies of God's people
using Old Testament imagery of two
armies going to war okay so it's it's
symbolic in nature then it's not talking
about literal birds I mean even even in
the whole chapter talks about Jesus
coming on a white horse and a sharp
sword proceeding out of his mouth verse
21 says you know he killed those with
the sword that came out of his mouth
those again it's it's a description
Jesus doesn't come with a sharp sword
but it's a symbolic the sword represents
the Word of God the Bible speaks of the
sword is the sharp two-edged sword the
word of God so once again Revelation is
symbolic but really this whole passage
just refers to the defeat of the enemies
of God when Jesus comes the second time
so that is the big focus that we have of
this passage again if you'd like to
learn more about the second coming of
Christ and what the Bible says about
that our free offer is called the
ultimate resource we mentioned that
in the program to receive it just call
our resource line it's 883 five six
seven four seven until next week friends
may God bless
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
charts and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dhic index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five three eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy study Bible stance apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore com or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
what if you could know the future what
would you do what would you change to
see the future you must understand the
past Alexander the Great becomes king
when he's only 18 but he's a military
prodigy a hundred and fifty years in
advance Cyrus had been named
Nebuchadnezzar built the city as a
showcase to the entire world
Rome was violent they were ruthless
they were determined
this intriguing documentary hosted by
pastor Doug Batchelor explores the most
striking Bible prophecies that have been
dramatically fulfilled throughout
history kingdoms in time an
extraordinary adventure through the
Bible's most amazing fulfilled
prophecies are you ready this at AF
bookstore com for over 50 years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world we build churches in India
proclaim God's Word in China and have
sent free Bible studies around the globe
today's program and free resources were
made possible by our ministry partners
caring individuals like you if you've
been blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with the Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air so the
blessings you've received can be shared
with others to find out more about
becoming a ministry partner please visit
our website
[Music]
to take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 may sing fax 0 RG